I knew that human lifespans are short,
so why didn't I want to know more?Your
life after this
will be much longer than we can even imagine.It's about
time, then.  Want to
know more about humans?
[Music]
Would you like to take a disciple? He's my disciple. He's good at magic. He knows what I'm
like. He's the same as me.
Even if I am reborn, it is
important to Prile-sama.I
don't know, so I
wanted to find out.My master said that because of you, Hero Ichi's
adventure was a waste of time.He said that it
was a very enjoyable journey.  I'm so
happy that you tried to get to know me, even though I don't know anything about you. Even my adventures with Sumitomo aren't even one part of my life.
[Music]
Who will go to heaven when they die?  Well, I guess
I did indeed come true.
[Music]
Ah.